البدايه من لوتوانيا حيث اختتمت اعمال قمه
النيتو بحضور زعماء دول الحلف والرئيس
الاوكراني وعلى هامش القمه اصدر قاده
مجموعه دول السبع بيانا عبروا فيه عن
الدعم لاوكرانيا في دفاعها عن نفسها ضد
العدوان الروسي مهما طال امده بحسب البيان
مجموعه الدول السبع اعلنت عن خطتها
للضمانات الامنيه لاوكرانيا وتشمل تقديم
مساعدات امنيه ومعدات عسكريه حديثه وتؤكد
انكافدت بتعزيز الشفافيه والمساءله ينضم
الينا من فيلم يوسفي لوتوانيا
عبد الله الشامي ومن موسكو تنضم الينا
مراسله الجزيره كارمن جو خضار سابدا معك
وجد من البيان الذي صدر عن مجموعه السبع
بدعم اوكرانيا
كان هذا البيان على شكل ظهور شخصي لقاده
مجموعه السبع ورئيس الوزراء الياباني
ومسؤولين اخرين على
منصه خلال هذا الظهور تحدث عدد منهم
الرئيس بايدن اكد
بانه طمعنا الرئيس الاوكراني زيلنسكي ازاء
قضيه تقديم ضمانات امنيه بعيده الامد
لاوكرانيا اكد له ذلك جاء هذا الظهور
للقاده
بعد او ضمن ما يسمى من قبل مجموعه السبع
والناتو بالاعلان المشترك لدعم اوكرانيا
دعم اوكرانيا وفقا لهذا الاعلان السي
عسكريا وسياسيا على الساحه الدوليه عسكريا
من خلال من خلال اعاده بناء الجيش
الاوكراني برا وجوا وبحرا بحيث يكون قادرا
على ردعي
هجوم مستقبليا ضد الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وكذلك صد اي هجمات على اراضيها هذا هو
الهدف من اعلان من الاعلان المشترك لدعمي
اوكرانيا هو اعلان غير مسبوق في اوروبا
شبيه لحقيقه الدعم
لاسرائيل من حيث الهيكليه التفاصيل تفاصيل
هذا الاعلان المشترك ما زالت لم تردنا من
البيت الابيض بشكل رسمي ولكن هناك الكثير
من التسريبات التي تؤكد بان هذا الدعم سوف
يمكن اوكرانيا من الدفاع عن اراضيها ومن
الحفاظ على سيادتها
واستقلاليتها ضد اي عدوان مستقبلي عبد
الله الشامي ماذا عن مجريات قمه النيتو
التي تختتم في هذه الاثناء
نعم القمه بالفعل اختتم بهذه الاثناء هناك
مؤتمر صحفي للامين العام يجمل فيه ما تم
الاتفاق عليه او لنقل يعيد ذكر النقاط
التي اعلنها الحلف في بيانه بالامس بعد ان
اقر حزمه مساعدات متعدده السنوات كما اطلق
عليها للدعم لكي تكون جاهزا للانضمام
عندما يتم دعوتها الى عضويه الحلف بالفعل
اوكرانيا لم تتلقى هذه الدعوه كما كان
يامر رئيسها لكنها تلقت المقابل اختصارا
لمسار العضويه طريقا اكثر لكي تكون عضوا
في الحلم دون تحديد مدى زمني وان كان
الامر مرهونا اكثر بانتهاء الحرب لان دول
الحلف على ما يبدو رغم الخلافات بين
معسكريها الشرقي والغربي اتفقت على ان
الوقت الان هو لا يناسب لان دخول اوكرانيا
هو دخول للحلف في حرب مع روسيا وهم لا
يريده او ما لا تريده هذه الدول البالغ
عددها واحدا 31 لكن في المقابل راينا ان
السويد التي خلال الاشهر الماضيه او
بالاحرى منذ قمه مدريد العام الماضي كانت
تنتظر الموافقه التركيه تلقت هذه الموافقه
لبضع عمليه الانضمام هناك ايضا اعتماد
لزياده الانفاق الدفاعي للدول الاعضاء
ليصبح نسبه 2% من الناتج القومي هي ليست
السقف وانما هي بدايه ما يمكن لكل دوله او
ما يجب عليها ان تنفقه فيما يخص هذا الامر
ايضا تم الاتفاق على ان تكون هناك خطوات
في ما لها علاقه بتطوير القدرات العسكريه
والدفاعيه الكيب لكي تكون قادره على حمايه
حدود الحلف الشرقيه خصوصا تلك التي مع
روسيا عندما تنضم كان هناك ايضا حديث عن
تعاون اكبر مع من يطلق عليه من الدول
الشركاء نتحدث عن اليابان وكوريا
واستراليا ونيوزلندا هي قمه كما قال عنها
الامين العام سواء الان في هذا المؤتمر او
حتى في البدايه قمه تاريخيه بالفعل
استطاعت ان تكون كما قال على قدر التنافس
وقال ايضا
ضمن البيان الذي صدر امس ان روسيا من
الصعب ان يكون الحلف في حاله حوار معها
وان كان البيان لم يستبعد امكانيه القيام
بذلك اذا ما قامت موسكو بايقاف حربها
حربها التي تقول او التي يطلق عليها الحلف
حرب عدوانيه وانها يجب ان تقف وان اي سلام
يجب ان يكون في صالح اوكرانيا وليس لصالح
اعطاء روسيا وقت تستفيد به لاعاده ربما
تسليح نفسها بالتالي هي قمه كما يقول على
الاقل شركاء وحلفاء النيدو كانت على قدر
التوقعات فيما يخص الدعم الاوكراني وكذلك
في ضم دوله جديده وينتظر خلال الاشهر
القادمه من خلال هذا المجلس الذي تم
الاعنه اليوم مجلس العلاقات بين الحلف
واوكرانيا تمهيد الطريق اكثر لانضمام الى
الحلف ربما خلال العام المقبل
اذا لا عضويه
لاوكرانيا في النيتو في هذه المرحله ولكن
ضمانات امنيه متقدمه كيف كان وقع ذلك في
روسيا
ضمانات امنيه يعني سلاح اضافيه لاوكرانيا
وهذا الامر تحدث عنه الذي قال ان الصراع
في اوكرانيا مستمر ولن ينتهي قبل ان يعود
الغرب عن مسعاه لو وصفه ووصفه بالحاق
هزيمه استراتيجيه بروسيا اذا عدم ضم
الناتو ولكن في المقابل عدم ضم اوكرانيا
عفوا ولكن في المقابل منحها مزيد من
الاسلحه يعني ان هذا الصراع مستمر يعني ان
هذه الحرب سيطول امدها وكانت روسيا قد
عبرت مرارا عن هذا الموقف قالت ان مد
اوكرانيا بمزيد من السلاح يعني القتال
وقتال الغرب حتى اخر اوكرانيا هكذا تتعامل
السي روسيا مع هذه القمه تقول ان حلف شمال
الاطلسي هو اصلا حلف ينشر العدوان وايضا
ينشر عدم الاستقرار في المنطقه
[ضحك]
اليوم هذا المشهد الذي تظاهر يمكن القول
في ليتوانيا تتعامل معه موسكو على انه
نظام عالمي جديد يتظاهر في هذه المرحله
الحديث عن علاقه موسكو
بالقول انما تقوم به الدولتان هو في صالح
العالم وفي صالح السلام وليس موجها ضد اي
دوله اخرى اذا هذه الضمانات التي تم
الحديث عنها اليوم في ليتوانيا سيتبعها
بطبيعه الحال خطوات او حتى تصريحات من قبل
موسكو وايضا تاكيد كان على لسان ميدفي على
لسان بوسكوب على لسان لافروف الذي يتواجد
اليوم في الهند بان روسيا مستمره في هذه
الحرب ومسعاها لتحقيق ما تصفه بالنصر
مستمر شكرا لكم
شبكه مراسلين اذا كارمن جو خضار من روسيا
عبد الله الشامي ووجد وقفي من العاصمه
الليتوانيه